all right it's time for seeing an unseen
where we expose the big cultural stories
of the day all the lamestream media is
peddling milania conspiracy theories
white late-night comedy is dead and
musicians vs. politicians at a softball
game all right joining us down all the
details Raymond Arroyo Fox News
contributor New York Times best-selling
author a brand-new book well Wilder the
amulet of power all right Raymond why
are the gals at the view
spreading conspiracy theories about the
first lady can take anymore
used by these this one is really
unbelievable over the weekend the
president the first lady toured Alabama
to console victims of those terrible
tornadoes they took dozens of lives
story started spreading on the internet
claiming that this was not Milania at
the president's side but a body double
joy behar and the ladies of the view
cleared it up this way that one does not
look like her sorry I wasn't gonna go
along with this but that wasn't that
picture doesn't I know you weren't gonna
go now you will know it's a different
shaped face you know I spent like a
machine to say I spent like an hour on
Saturday involved in this that's Milania
is not a very tall statuesque woman and
the one that we saw the first one that
we showed she's she looks kind of short
when there's a rumor like this and memes
all over the place I think it catches on
because there's an element of truth to
the idea that she doesn't want to spend
time with him I haven't been on the view
in a long time
invite me on well they will do a little
comparison a photo an element of truth
and what is the element of truth except
your own ideology where there's
obviously a bias against this visual aid
you're kidding Stephanie Grisham the the
first lady's spokesman came out and said
this is shameless
particularly when they were there to
console victim it wasn't very beautiful
the first day trash Trump for signings
on the bar because people were going to
get into on Fox oh we're gonna get on
fox nation yeah cuz I wanted to talk
about that right the other thing about
this is I I can't believe they pro mode
their next segment I guess tomorrow on
the fact that we really didn't land on
the moon
coming up landing was faked now Laura I
heard on the internet that Joy Behar
occasionally employs a body double look
at that I'm sure I'm sure that only has
an element of the truth to it we'll
leave it there Oh Dustin Hoffman's gonna
get royalties on that one speaking of
Canadians there is a related story Jay
Leno I'm sorry toy Jay Leno was on The
Today Show you opened yourself up to it
and Jay was talking this week about
whether he missed late-night TV his
answer was telling I don't miss it you
know everything now is if people don't
like your politics they everyone has to
know your politics so now it's all very
serious it's everything is just so so
now I just like seeing a bit of civility
come back to you know in all the comics
Jimmy and then Colbert and everybody
else it's tough when when when that's
the one that's the common age everything
they've made it about this Laura they've
made it all about politics and the
audience is fleeing from it this is why
the overall audience is way down from
when Jay Leno or god forbid Johnny
Carson was presiding over the Tonight
Show it is a ruin and I think it's
because not only has the comedy as Jay
said got nasty and petty and very
politically well if not fun this is the
this is the cardinal sin it's not funny
and it's the very thing comedy should
teach us what we have in common and have
us laugh to get each other rather it
accentuates the things that divide us
and half the audience Renoir since said
this years ago
before he died he said I never thought I
should spout off about politics I'm here
to make people laugh right I'm here to
entertain them shut up and make us laugh
make us laugh
all right well joy behar actually makes
our point or Jay Leno's point about this
she said this today I did stand-up up
until Obama came in and then I was
losing interest because he was too good
and there was nothing to make fun of
them upon Anza there it is
she loved Obama but Bush and Trump are a
cornucopia this is I'm sorry there's
plenty of humor to have on both sides a
good comedian
should make well parenting dating or all
sorts of things about life foibles
aplenty jerry seinfeld could make us
laugh about the socks and the dryer by
the way who are the three most popular
comedians up here
kevin hart seinfeld and jay leno long a
battle has been brewing since the reagan
administration between musicians and
politicians about using songs for
political rallies you know the songs
that become anthems for a campaign like
these
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Elizabeth Warren has run into some hot
water for using that Dolly Parton hit
apparently her spokesman said her
partner manager we did not approve the
request and we do not approve requests
like this of a political nature now
Laura the law on this is kind of dodgy
remember Bruce Springsteen went after
Ronald Reagan Tom Petty went after
George Bush for using their songs the
law is if a venue has the music rights
that broadcast
you know performance rights they can
play it in the arena but if it's
broadcast
the musician has some publicity rights
because they say this looks like a false
endorsement I and that's where you get
into some problems gay but many Queen
REM Adele the stones they've all sent
cease and desist letters to Donald Trump
he hasn't stopped you what are the
enforcement mechanism I still don't get
you can't always get what you want but
you get wait I don't either I don't
understand you pick something Bush is
taking care of business we got to go
back to Bachman Turner overdrive in 1974
to get that music somebody did
that's the